Four months before Steve Jobs planned
to reveal the iPhone to the world,
he decided to switch the screen from plastic to
glass, because plastic was too easily scratched.
Engineers freaked out because they didn’t have
a glass prototype that could
pass the one-meter drop test.
There was, however, an American glassware
company that had once prototyped a strong,
scratch-proof product dubbed “gorilla
glass” but didn’t have a market for it.
Jobs doubted the glass was good enough and started
lecturing Corning CEO Wendell
Weeks on how glass was made.
Weeks boldly interjected, as described in
Walter Issaacson’s book: “Can you shut up,
and let me teach you some science?”
Jobs was convinced. But Weeks said
his company didn’t have the capacity
to make the gorilla glass in its
factories, to which Jobs said:
“Don’t be afraid. Yes, you can do it.
Get your mind around it. You can do it.”
And Corning did do it.
The day the iPhone came out, Jobs sent Weeks this
message: “We couldn’t have done it without you.”